soit qu'on est un peu l'antithèse aux
réalités des menus macro et même de
macross d'un président il l'a montré qui
est à la fois un mondialiste ouverture
grand marché mondial qu'une entreprise
soit française ou étrangère ça n'a pas
d'importance moi je crois que le rôle du
pouvoir c'est d'abord de protéger de
protéger les français et le domaine
économique ou s'il n'y avait pas que
question de sécurité d'autorité comme
été un échec un échec total et puis le
président macron depuis cinq ans la
montre est fondamentalement il est un
social démocrate qui pensent que tous
les problèmes du pays peuvent se régler
pour de la part de la redistribution
nous nous croyons fortement que c'est la
pire des insultes à être un social
démocrate un cheval peut-être pire des
insultes mais c'est la réalité de ce
qu'il est c'est à dire que pour lui tout
tout doit toujours terminer par de la
dépense publique nous nous considérons
qu'aujourd'hui ce pays il étouffe sous
le poids de la dette que toute la
créativité que tout les caps et
d'initiatives de tous nos concitoyens
que la soutenabilité de la situation
économique du pays est aujourd'hui mise
en péril par par la dette et la dépense
publique dont il faut inventer autre
chose et ce que nous proposons